[Music]
on this Sunday night the volunteers
risking their lives in Libya it's quite
a massive risk that that they are facing
right now overwhelmed Aid workers
struggle to cope with the magnitude of
the disaster
sigh of relief in the maritimes host
tropical storm Lee Fades the leaves
behind quite the cleanup
Ukraine's next phase but it is a
humbling experience The crucial training
from Canadian soldiers
wheels and scabs backlash and back
pedaling Drew Barrymore deletes a
tearful apology amid the Hollywood
strike
global national with paranasser
scale of the destruction
unimaginable
buildings even entire neighborhoods
flattened or simply washed away when two
dams broke flooding the Libyan city of
derna Drone footage shows how the
torrent of water carved deep channels
through what had been once homes schools
mosques and shops
good evening and thanks for joining us
before the floods hit Libya's government
was on the verge of collapse now as Dan
Spector reports though help is slowly
trickling in that instability is making
it difficult for Aid Crews and
volunteers on the ground
rescue teams in derna Libya spent their
Sunday painstakingly searching for signs
of Life In A mud-caked Wasteland where
hundreds of buildings have been reduced
to Rubble mostly what they find is death
as a Libyan when I hold bodies I cry
says this volunteer I can't hold my
tears a raging wall of water tore
through the center of the city of over
one hundred thousand people watching
entire residential blocks out to sea the
United Nations now estimates 11 300
people were killed with ten thousand
more missing Libyan officials dispute
that saying the death toll is 3200 that
disagreement a sign of the complicated
road ahead in a country that lacks a
strong central government
I saw people dying in front of me I saw
death says this woman building this home
where she and her husband raised their
children was a lifelong dream in an
instant that dream became a nightmare we
are witnessing quite a high increase of
the basic needs of the survivors the
affected population that survived the
flooding as they lack everything from
proper shelter food water medicine help
is arriving Rescuers from France set up
this field Hospital teams from Algeria
could be seen searching the rubble on
Sunday over a dozen countries are
involved in relief efforts but getting
supplies to where they're needed is
complicated the flooding caused quite
severe damage on the vital
infrastructure namely the roads and the
bridges
adding further difficulty to recovery
efforts the international Committee of
the Red Cross says land mines left
behind in previous military conflicts
were strewn about By the Waters meaning
just combing through the rubble could
prove deadly for international Aid
workers and volunteers quite a massive
risk that that they are facing she says
more teams on Route will attempt to
calculate just how much food medicine
and other Basics will be needed in the
coming weeks months and possibly years
to inspector Global News
even stepping behind the bench for the
team Mike Babcock has resigned as the
head coach of the NHL Columbus Blue
Jackets
the former Toronto Maple Leafs coach who
at one point was considered the best in
the league had been in hot water since a
former NHL player said he demanded to
see pictures on his players phones
Babcock says it wasn't an invasion of
privacy rather awake to get to know his
players still the players union launched
a review and updated the league Friday
on its findings
the summer break for MPS ends tomorrow
and Parliament is back in session the
Liberals and conservatives have both
wrapped up caucus meetings in the past
week or so and there is of course no
shortage of issues affecting Canadians
to square off over our Ottawa bureau
chief Mercedes Stevenson joins us now
Mercedes thanks for being with us what
will be the strategy for the parties
going into this session
well it's really a tale of two party
leaders with very different political
fortunes over the summer that have
changed fairly significantly since we
would have last talked about this in
around June for Justin Trudeau this has
really been the summer of discontent not
just with Canadians where he's seeing
significantly sliding pool numbers that
he should probably be quite concerned
about but also within his own caucus and
his own cabinet and it seems like
nothing he's been able to do has changed
the channel they haven't come up with
any sort of new grand strategic ideas
which might be what's needed some
liberals think it might be the question
of whether they need a new leader and if
that's the case he's going to have to
fend off leadership Rivals as well going
into the fall for Pierre pauliev it's
about maintaining this new momentum that
he's gaining he is 15 points ahead of
Justin Trudeau According to some of the
polls that is quite significant he has
softened His Image over the summer we've
been introduced and for many Canadians
introduced for the first time to a new
Pierre pauliev we've met his wife we've
met his children he's in a t-shirt he
doesn't have glasses on and he's really
focusing on something that a lot of
people are thinking about all the time
and that is how difficult it is to pay
their bills if he can maintain that
which he needs to going forward and
convince Canadians that he has an
alternative to Justin Trudeau that
really is going to be his goal for the
fall as well as starting to Define his
policies and his platform
and he has time to do that I mean the
next federal election is still two years
out so is there a chance he's peaked too
early
so that's a great question because it's
always a danger for opposition leaders
we have seen various opposition leaders
Peak and it looked like they might
overtake the government and then they
essentially step on some self-created
disaster and sink into that trap he'll
have to be able to avoid it but he's
really focusing on messaging that he
thinks is going to register take a
listen to what he had to say about
Transit and housing last week
my Common Sense plan will require
high density housing right next to
Transit stations look at this appalling
scene behind me today look at this just
take a moment
what do you see here you see a transit
station
where's the housing
so we're spending billions of dollars on
Transit stations across the country
where there are no people allowed to
live
so Pierre poliov is going to need to
come up with actual plans to do things
if he wants to be elected Justin Trudeau
is going to have to convince people he
has a new bold Vision eight years in
those are both tough things to do and
Faro we're still potentially two years
out from the next election that's right
but this week ahead I know you'll be
paying close attention to what happens
thanks so much our Ottawa bureau chief
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thanks
also this week Ukrainian president
vlodimir zielinski will travel to New
York to address the U.N General Assembly
his forces now claim to have retaken a
tactically important Village South of
the Frontline city of bakmut
military officials released a video
showing Ukrainian soldiers holding Flags
in front of destroyed buildings
Ukrainian forces have been conducting
offensives north and south at beg mode
for months ever since it fell to the
Russians in May
today Canada's defense minister joined
Canadian troops at a training base in
England where they held a special salute
to a group of Ukrainian recruits
departing for the war Global's Redmond
Shannon was there
a somber salute from Canadian troops as
four busloads of Ukrainian forces head
home from this British military training
camp these soldiers that come through
here are fighting for their freedom
their Homeland their families and their
future and it is an absolute privilege
to be a part of that process and help
them to do that 170 Canadian soldiers
have been based at this camp for the
past year and have trained 2600
ukrainians part of Canada's operation
unifier to help build Ukraine's military
capacity the majority of the ukrainians
who come here were until recently
civilians and after a five-week
intensive training program go home to
Ukraine to fight in a war
we just need to
the enemy from our land these bastards
Grizzly is a Furniture maker and is
married with two kids he never held a
gun before coming here
I really really enjoying being here
especially Canadian structures they're
tough but still I do enjoy like working
training with them as part of his visit
to Europe Canada's defense minister Bill
Blair stopped by for the salute and to
meet the Canadian trainers the training
that's being provided here I believe in
the evidence that the ukrainians have
provided us is is actually saving lives
it's helping them be far more effective
in in their military response to Russian
aggression Blair also announced that
some of Canada's previously pledged
financing to Ukraine will go toward air
defense systems my perception is that
Canadians overwhelmingly understand not
unanimously but but I think very very
overwhelmingly there's a strong
consensus of our responsibility to
support Ukraine Canada has pledged more
than eight billion dollars in Aid and
Military assistance to Ukraine since the
start of Russia's full invasion but it
is many of these new recruits who will
pay the ultimate price Redmond Shannon
Global News in the southeast of England
the crews are now working on power
restoration and cleanup after
post-tropical Cyclone Lee made landfall
yesterday the storm brought with it
Fierce winds and heavy rainfall at one
point knocking out power for more than
200 000 people between Nova Scotia and
New Brunswick yep despite all that as
Callum Smith reports it didn't cause the
damage some had feared all right
Crews continue to clear debris off this
Nova Scotia road making significant
progress compared to Saturday Lynette
Burns was ready for it and captured
these photos to help tell the story this
ocean this road and the pond behind me
were one yesterday and even on top of
that there was still 30 40-foot storm
surge coming in I've never seen anything
like it
foreign
[Music]
airport flights are resuming although
it's taking some time to get back up and
running after they're all halted during
the height of the storm Saturday
changing up plans for some two days so
far and we are hoping to get out tonight
on
on the plane they said it's ready this
morning I expected to come to the
airport today and see people laying all
over the floor and sleeping on their
luggage and blinds I was just shocked at
how in control it seems some trees were
hammered to the ground in the historic
King Square in Saint John while a few
roads took a beating outside the
Fredericton area across the region
internet and power outages persist
although the number of people off the
grid has shrunk at the peak of the storm
nearly 300 000 customers across Nova
Scotia were without power we don't have
the estimated times for frustration for
everybody but we do know that a
significant number will be restored
today and a lot more tomorrow as well
Lee was initially heading straight for
Yarmouth in Southwestern Nova Scotia the
concern was there and what we got was a
lot less than expected so all good
allowing some maritimers to breathe a
bit of a sigh of relief at least this
time Callum Smith Global News Halifax
now Lee has lost much of its strength
but the hurricane season still isn't
over with more storms ahead Global News
chief meteorologist Anthony Farnell is
in Nova Scotia Anthony how are
conditions there right now and what
other systems should we be watching out
for
the Bay of Fundy behind me much calmer
today than it was yesterday as Lee was
moving by that system now weakening
quickly moving across Newfoundland and
heading back out into the Atlantic now
the Atlantic hurricane season just
reached the Midway point last week as
far as storms go there's another one in
the Atlantic Nigel expected to become a
major hurricane according to the
National Hurricane Center over the next
couple of days big waves are once again
a possibility for the Atlantic Shores
but the center of Niger will stay well
off the coast as it recurves into the
Atlantic the following name would be
Ophelia that may too develop in a couple
of days time and the latest predictions
are for the next few weeks to remain
very active the big question is do any
of those names end up making their way
back into Atlantic Canada and as for
right now it's just too early to tell
one thing that I will note is that with
a warming Atlantic and those ocean
temperatures are definitely warmer now
than a couple of years ago that affects
the strength and size of these systems
as they come ashore and that's what
we've seen lately
okay Global News meteorologist Anthony
farnella Nova Scotia thanks for that
the Relentless fight for action and
answers in Canada's landfills coming up
tomorrow's day of protest and growing
calls to keep searching for Secrets
buried beneath the waist
calls to search a Winnipeg landfill for
human remains are growing people across
Canada will gather tomorrow for a day of
action to show solidarity with the
families of two indigenous women whose
bodies are believed to be buried there
Catherine dornian reports
tomorrow protesters will bring a message
to governments across the country
rallies are planned in major cities from
Victoria to Halifax in Winnipeg where
the movement began organizers say
hundreds will take to the steps of the
Manitoba legislature we share
experiences we remember our loved ones
we see their names
and we remind the people that we are
people these protests reignited in July
after Premier Heather Stephenson refused
to support a search of a Winnipeg area
landfill for the remains of two
indigenous women Morgan Harris and
Mercedes Myron were killed last year
along with two others Rebecca cantwa and
buffalo woman who remains unidentified a
Winnipeg man is charged with
first-degree murder in their deaths so
we're gonna keep getting louder you're
gonna keep hearing our voices the call
to search the landfill has galvanized
both indigenous people and allies all
across the country Priscilla omullo
organizing tomorrow's protest in
Victoria says the story of these women
has touched a nerve there's a level of
you know for indigenous folks
um could I be next and for the
non-indigenous folks trying to figure
out how do I be an ally Where Do We Go
From Here what do I do she believes
Canadians are experiencing a watershed
moment of Reckoning with Colonial
history and this demonstrates that the
promises of reconciliation need to be
backed up with concrete action people
are speaking of reconciliation and they
think it's moving along just fine you
know but a genuine step would be to
bring these women home to their families
Tara Martinez in Winnipeg says it will
be a powerful day and hopes this is the
last protest they will need to do feels
good to know that our voices have
reached far and wide
you know all eyes are on the landfills
right now knowing how many people have
heard the call she's now looking to
politicians to answer it Catherine
dornian Global News Winnipeg
the Olympics of oil and gas are taking
place in Calgary ahead the energy
transition promises and pitches from the
world petroleum Congress
Calgary is hosting the world petroleum
Congress this week bringing together 5
000 delegates for more than 60 countries
now the theme of this year's meeting is
energy transition but as Heather York's
West explains this isn't a conference
about reaching climate targets
the world petroleum Congress has come to
Calgary with delegates from around the
world focusing their attention on the
future of oil and gas there'll be two
billion more people on the planet by
2050 how are we going to make sure that
everybody has the energy they need in a
way that's affordable and reliable the
energy transition is top of mind at this
year's for day Summit with a focus on
the industry's plans around the world to
decarbonize in Canada the top oil sense
producers have formed the pathways
Alliance on track its President says to
get the industry to Net Zero by 2050. as
one of the major oil producers in the
world it comes with a responsibility to
also be a leader in energy transition
and in reducing greenhouse gas emissions
because we know the urgency of the
climate imperative but critics point out
the energy industry is far from focused
on the transition alone in August the
new CEO of Suncor a member of the
pathways Alliance told shareholders the
company plans to shift Focus back to its
core operations we have a bit of a
disproportionate emphasis on the longer
term energy transition today we win by
creating value through our large
integrated asset Base underpinned by oil
sands the CEO of Shell Canada agrees if
you are a company that is servicing its
cup customers that are still demanding a
fossil fuel energy source it's very
difficult to then not provide your
customers with that energy they demand
Susan Pierce said that's a very clear
message that says you know until there's
a regulatory requirement for companies
to actually decarbonize they're not
going to do it there will be no emission
reduction Target agreements at the end
of this Summit organizers say the goal
is ultimately for Global producers to
network and learn in Canada though
climate regulations are coming the
promise of a federal emissions cap is
deeply unpopular within the industry but
it's a policy Ottawa says will be
announced by the end of the year Heather
urich's West Global News Calgary
[Music]
next giant steel Jaws the transfer of a
huge Canadian T-Rex made of steel
[Music]
at Chilliwack BC artist is putting the
finishing touches on a giant stainless
steel Tyrannosaurus Rex Kevin Stones
been working on the life-size sculpture
for two years building it in sections
and in the coming days the pieces are
going to be trucked to a winery in the
Okanagan Valley where it will be put up
and put together spanning approximately
the size of a bus
after facing industry blowback from
friends and fans actor Drew Barrymore
says she's hitting pause on the planned
restarter for daytime talk show this all
comes after announcing she would be back
on the air despite the ongoing strikes
in Hollywood Jennifer Johnson reports
I deeply apologize to writers
I deeply apologize to unions actress
Drew Barrymore posted an emotional
apology on social media after announcing
she was restarting production of her
daytime talk show despite two Hollywood
unions on strike but on Sunday Barrymore
put the brakes on her show after
pressure and criticism even from friends
I love her very much I grew up with her
but I'm not sure that this was the right
the right move the Writers Guild of
America representing 11 000 television
movie and Creative Media writers has
been on strike since May demanding
higher wages and clearer Provisions in
their contracts about artificial
intelligence this is obviously way
bigger than just the Drew Barrymore show
and Essay writers we are out here
standing with our Union
sag aftra a guild representing over 160
thousand actors and others in the
entertainment and television industry
also went on strike in July Barrymore
was within sag after a strike guidelines
to keep protect action running on our
talk show but anyone writing for the
show would be crossing the writer's
Guild picket line
scabs while many television shows have
gone dark or are running repeat episodes
some talk shows not governed by writer's
Guild rules because they are largely
unscripted remain on the air including
the view and Live with Kelly and Mark
union leaders blame Hollywood studio
heads for the strikes it's because of
these top tier highly greedy
self-absorbed executives
that frankly are ruining it for
everybody but themselves
as tens of thousands remain out of work
the strikes have also been costly for
California where most films and TV shows
are produced costing the state about 5
billion dollars so far
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
and that's global national for this
Sunday night I'm Farah Nasser and
tonight's your Canada is the annual
celebration of a Canadian hero
43 years after Terry Fox's marathon of
Hope his mission to raise money for
cancer research continues in this year's
Edition saw about 4 million Canadians
participating Donna will be back with
you tomorrow until next time take care
of yourselves and each other good night
foreign
[Music]